[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute kommt ein sehr gefragtes Rezept.
Ich werde nämlich Mantı machen.
Mantı sind kleine Teigtaschen gefüllt mit Hackfleisch
oder auch mit Linsen oder auch Kartoffeln.
Das Ganze gibt es in der Türkei,
gibt es aber auch in vielen anderen Ländern.
Aus Russland kenne ich sie
oder auch aus der afghanischen Küche.
Vielleicht kennt ihr ja noch weitere Länder,
wo es eben auch Mantı gibt.
Ich denke, vom Grundgedanken her
gibt es die wahrscheinlich in jedem Land,
nur sind sie anders geformt, anders gefüllt
und sehen einfach ein bisschen anders aus.
Ich werde jetzt zuerst mal den Teig herstellen.
Dafür brauche ich
– also ich mache eine große Menge –
1700 Gramm Mehl,
– ich habe jetzt hier ein Dinkelmehl, das 630er –
750 Gramm warmes Wasser,
drei Eier,
2 Teelöffel Salz
und 30 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl.
Ja, das sind die Grundzutaten.
Und ich mache jetzt eine große Menge,
denn Mantı eignen sich hervorragend zum Einfrieren.
Und ich denke mir dann immer,
wenn man sich schon die Arbeit macht,
dann macht man gleich eine große Menge
und hat direkt was auf Vorrat.
Ihr könnt jetzt den Teig mit der Hand verkneten
oder mit der Küchenmaschine.
Ich mache das jetzt hier ganz einfach in der Küchenmaschine.
Ich gebe jetzt erst mal nur zwei Drittel Mehl rein.
Dann kommt hier das Wasser dazu.
Die Eier gebe ich rein.
Ich muss sagen, meine Mama,
mit der haben wir früher oft Mantı zusammen gemacht,
aber so in den letzten Jahren irgendwie nicht mehr.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es einfach viel Arbeit ist.
Und als ich noch zu Hause gewohnt habe,
haben wir sie halt immer schön zusammen geformt.
Und jetzt...
Ja, jetzt mache ich Mantı und gebe sie meiner Mama.
Ja.
Das sollte man tun
als gute Tochter.
Und jetzt den Teig schön verkneten.
Und ich gebe dann einfach nach und nach
noch das restliche Mehl dazu.
Es sollte ein fester Teig sein,
nicht zu weich, also nicht wie Hefeteig,
aber auch nicht so hart wie Nudelteig,
also so eine gesunde Zwischenmischung.
[Musik]
Hui!
Das ist wie so eine Zutatenrutsche.
[Musik]
Und je nach Mehlsorte kann es sein,
dass ihr das ganze Mehl braucht
oder ein bisschen weniger.
Bei Dinkel braucht man eher etwas weniger,
weil Dinkel einfach mehr Flüssigkeit aufzieht.
Weizenmehl hätte ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich komplett aufgebraucht.
Aber ich glaube,
das reicht schon.
Ich teste den mal kurz.
Ah, er ist schon noch weich,
aber er darf ja auch nicht so hart werden.
Ich glaube, noch einen Esslöffel gebe ich dazu
oder zwei
und lasse den jetzt etwa fünf bis zehn Minuten kneten,
bis er schön geschmeidig ist.
Und wenn ihr das per Hand macht
– ist ein bisschen anstrengend bei der großen Menge.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Teig perfekt.
O Gott, ist das viel Teig!
Und jetzt lasse ich den ein bisschen ruhen,
einfach hier in einer Schüssel.
Schön abdecken.
Und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich
mich schon mal um die Füllung kümmern.
Ich mache sie jetzt ganz traditionell
mit einer Hackfleischfüllung
und werde jetzt gleich hierfür mein Hackfleisch selber machen.
Und die Füllung besteht auch nur aus zwei Zutaten,
nämlich Hackfleisch und einer Zwiebel.
Und da kommen dann noch Gewürze dazu.
[Musik]
Für die Füllung zerkleinere ich 750 Gramm Rinderhackfleisch.
Das sollte etwas mager sein.
Und danach kann ich direkt die Zwiebel
– die habe ich bereits geschält
und in feine Stücke geschnitten –
auch direkt durch den Fleischwolf geben.
So wird sie extraklein.
Und jetzt kommen da einfach noch die Gewürze dazu.
Ich nehme jetzt einen Teelöffel Salz,
einen halben Teelöffel Pfeffer
und eine Prise Chili.
[Musik]
Und jetzt einfach alles gut vermischen.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal zuerst die traditionelle Art und Weise,
wie man Mantı herstellt.
Und zwar könnt ihr euch jetzt aus dem Teig
so ungefähr acht bis zehn Portionen machen.
Am besten zu einer Kugel formen.
Und den übrigen Teig immer schön abdecken,
damit er einfach nicht austrocknet.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch etwas Mehl
und öffnet den Teig, also rollt ihn aus.
Und das macht man eigentlich ganz traditionell
mit so einem Oklava.
Es erfordert ein bisschen Übung.
Und da muss ich auch dazu sagen,
dass ein normaler Ausrollstab da einfach nicht ausreicht.
Denn der Teig sollte schon recht dünn werden.
Also erst mal so ein bisschen öffnen.
Und jetzt könnt ihr praktisch diesen Stab nehmen,
den Teig aufwickeln
und dann mit den Händen öffnen.
Und dann wird er immer,
immer, immer dünner.
Darauf achten, dass nicht zu viel Mehl verwendet wird.
Denn ich muss ja auch die Teigtaschen gleich schließen.
Und zu dünn darf der Teig auch nicht sein,
also eher so Nudelstärke,
so 1 mm ungefähr.
Ups! Jetzt habe ich ihn zerrissen.
So.
Ich nehme den jetzt kurz von der Backmatte runter.
Denn ich werde ihn jetzt schneiden.
Und Mantı ist eigentlich so ein Gesellschaftsding.
Also man macht es im Prinzip mit der ganzen Familie,
mit den Kindern, mit dem Ehemann,
mit der Mama, mit der Schwester.
Und dann hat auch wirklich die ganze Familie was davon.
[Musik]
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch entweder ein Messer
oder ein Pizzarad.
Ich habe jetzt hier mein Bisiklet.
Denn damit kann ich
fünf Linien auf einmal zuschneiden sozusagen.
Ich mache das Ganze hier jetzt 3 cm breit.
Und in Kayseri in der Türkei, wo Mantı eben herkommen,
da ist es wirklich so, dass
– entweder sind es 21 oder 41, ich bin mir gerade unsicher –
aber 21 oder 41 Mantı auf einen Esslöffel passen.
Ja, auf einen Esslöffel.
Die sind...
Ja, maşallah.
Die sind wirklich so klein und...
Okay, das mache ich nicht.
Ich mache sie wirklich 3 mal 3 cm groß.
Und das ist schon klein.
Aber ihr könnt sie auch gerne größer oder kleiner zubereiten.
Meine Cousine hat die früher
immer mit dem Lineal ausgemessen,
damit jeder Streifen
– okay, es liegt in der Familie –
gleich ist.
[Musik]
Du denkst gerade: "Lohnt sich der Aufwand?"
>> JOSH: Ich denke mir gerade:
"Lohnt sich der Aufwand?"
>> SALLY: Ich sage dir, der Aufwand lohnt sich.
Aber das ist ja hier die traditionelle Art und Weise.
Ich zeige die euch kurz,
aber ich werde sie nach diesem Video nie wieder machen.
Denn ich zeige euch gleich eine einfache Variante,
die viel, viel schneller geht
und genauso gut schmeckt,
die vielleicht nicht die typische Optik hat,
aber die ich als Zweifachmama und Vollberufstätige
jederzeit zubereiten kann.
Aber ich wollte euch diese Methode trotzdem zeigen.
Nicht, dass einer behauptet, ich kann das nicht.
Nicht?
[Musik]
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch so ein kleines Quadrat
zwischen die Finger
und klappt sozusagen die vier Ecken so zusammen,
dass in der Mitte
wie so eine Kreuzung entsteht.
So.
Zack!
Und das mache ich jetzt mit allen,
mit dem kompletten restlichen Teig.
Und ich sage dann immer: "Wer nicht mitgeholfen hat,
die Mantı zu formen, darf sie auch nicht essen."
Guckt mal. Und so sehen die dann aus.
So ein kleines süßes Päckchen!
Also man muss im Prinzip darauf achten,
dass außen der Teig ein bisschen mehlig ist,
damit die Finger nicht dran kleben,
und innen sollte er halt schon ein bisschen zusammenkleben.
Und wenn man es perfekt macht,
hat man es mit einem Drücker sozusagen erledigt.
Ich gebe sie hier noch in so ein Blech mit ein bisschen Mehl.
Und wie gesagt, kann man die super vorbereiten
und dann eben auch einfrieren.
Entweder kann man sie vorbacken,
sodass sie einfach dann nicht mehr kleben,
und dann einfrieren
oder man lässt sie einfach
nebeneinander schön einfrieren
und packt sie dann in eine Tüte zum Beispiel
oder in ein Gefäß.
Aber es ist halt schon extrem viel Arbeit.
Also das eine hier mache ich jetzt fertig
und dann zeige ich euch gleich noch
eine Variante,
die einfacher geht.
Man könnte auch Dreiecke formen.
Aber das ist so die traditionelle
Art und Weise.
[Musik]
Portion eins ist geschafft.
Ich habe mir da jetzt auch
zwei fleißige Helferlein dazu geholt.
Aylin und Sarah
haben beide den Türkischtest bestanden.
Aylin, Sarah,
herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Jetzt zeige ich euch aber noch eine Methode,
die wirklich einfacher ist.
Denn ich muss sagen, ich mag zwar die traditionelle Form,
aber ich persönlich habe nicht die Zeit dazu.
Ich lasse die jetzt hier einfach ein bisschen antrocknen.
Das ist okay.
Also ihr könnt jetzt entweder
weiterhin mit dem Oklava praktisch
oder mit einem Ausrollstab ausrollen
oder ihr nehmt gleich noch die Nudelmaschine dazu.
Und so mache ich das jetzt.
Aber ich rolle es einmal ein bisschen vor.
Den übrigen Teig wieder schön abdecken.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich mein Nudelholz,
also meine Nudelwalze.
Und das ist jetzt so eine extragroße.
Die Standard, die wäre ungefähr so.
Ist auch okay.
Aber ich nehme jetzt die,
weil ich die dahabe.
Mh.
Ich falte es jetzt noch ein bisschen
wie beim Nudelteig,
damit ich die schöne volle Breite ausnutzen kann
und einen geraden Strang hinbekomme.
Und dann einfach immer dünner einstellen.
[Musik]
Also ich bin jetzt hier bis Stufe 5 gegangen.
Das reicht dann auch.
Dünner muss man es wirklich nicht machen.
Und jetzt könnt ihr die entweder wie gewohnt
fein schneiden und dann zubereiten wie gerade eben,
wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt die traditionelle Form,
oder ihr macht es jetzt einfach so:
Ihr nehmt euch die Hackfleischmasse
und platziert sie hier zu einem langen Strang.
[Musik]
Dann da oben noch mal der gleiche Strang.
Jetzt hier einmal umwickeln, also wie so eine kleine Rolle.
Und dann wickle ich es noch einmal so weit,
dass praktisch der Teig einmal noch mal außenrum geht.
Und jetzt schneidet ihr euch einfach eure kleinen Mantı zu.
Und die sehen dann aus wie so kleine Röllchen.
Finde ich auch ganz süß.
Und ich würde jetzt mal behaupten,
sie schmecken genauso gut.
Experten würden vielleicht sagen:
"Oh, das schmeckt schon ein bisschen anders."
Aber ich mache es jetzt so,
weil es wirklich zeitsparend ist.
Und so was kann man auch wirklich
mal im Alltag dann schön unterbringen.
Was?
>> JOSH: Dauert schon auch lange.
>> SALLY: Ach nee, komm!
Teig herstellen, kurz ausrollen mit der Maschine.
Komm, das geht schon schneller.
>> JOSH: Kurz selber Hackfleisch gemacht.
>> SALLY: Kurz selber Hackfleisch gemacht.
Das ist schon was, was ich machen würde.
>> JOSH: Für die Mittagspause?
>> SALLY: Für die Mittagspause.
Für so nach der Schule.
Okay, ist auch aufwendig.
Aber es ist immerhin
– nicht? –
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: vereinfacht.
Und für diejenigen, die jetzt sagen: "Alles zu viel Arbeit",
ihr könnt ja mein Sosyete Mantısı machen.
Da gibt es auch schon ein Rezept auf dem Kanal.
Da mache ich nämlich daraus
einfach so große Nudelschnecken.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt auch diese Portion fertig.
Ich habe aber noch einiges an Teig übrig.
Also ich bin noch nicht komplett fertig.
Aber ich zeige euch jetzt mal, wie man Mantı zubereitet.
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr sie einfrieren wollt,
so einfrieren.
Und wenn sie gefroren sind,
könnt ihr sie dann schön verpacken.
Wenn ihr sie jetzt so direkt in eine Schüssel verpackt,
dann verkleben sie einfach.
Entweder antrocknen vorher im Backofen
oder eben anfrieren und dann verpacken.
Jetzt habe ich hier einen großen Topf.
Da kommt Salz mit rein.
Und das Salz immer dann erst dazu geben,
wenn das Wasser schon kocht,
damit ihr einfach eure Kochtöpfe nicht beschädigt.
Denn das Salz landet unten am Boden
und kann dann einfach mit der Zeit
so kleine Löcher auch verursachen.
Deswegen wirklich immer erst,
wenn sich das Salz auflösen kann,
also wenn das Wasser heiß ist oder kocht.
Dann habe ich hier noch ein kleines Pfännchen.
Und zwar kann ich da schon mal
ein bisschen Butter dazu geben
für die Buttersoße.
Und bis das Wasser hier so weit ist
– wobei es ist gleich so weit.
Es ist so weit.
So. Jetzt kann ich hier meine Mantı kochen.
Und die brauchen so ungefähr 15 bis 20 Minuten,
je nachdem, wie groß sie sind,
je nachdem, wie dick eben auch der Teig ist.
Sie schwimmen dann einfach oben, wenn sie fertig sind.
Das dauert jetzt ein bisschen.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Soße zubereiten.
Ich nehme jetzt Joghurt, einen 3,5-prozentigen.
Und den würze ich mit Salz, Pfeffer und Knoblauch.
Okay, so ein Rieseneimer.
So richtig typisch türkisch, muss ich sagen.
Meine Mama, die hat auch immer
so fünf Kilo Joghurt im Kühlschrank.
Die Knoblauchzehe einfach dazu pressen
oder dazu reiben.
Und die werden einfach traditionell mit Joghurt gegessen.
So richtig lecker!
Josh, hast du jemals Mantı gegessen?
>> JOSH: Ich habe noch nie davon gehört!
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann darfst du gleich probieren,
wenn es fertig ist, okay?
>> JOSH: Ja, gerne.
>> SALLY: Weil ich muss sagen, so mit Joghurt
– ich liebe es ja.
Bei mir gibt es ja zu allem Joghurt.
Aber ich glaube, es ist nicht so
der typische europäische Geschmack,
sondern wirklich eher türkisch angehaucht.
Dann gebe ich noch ein bisschen Minze dazu.
So. Hier den Herd.
Und da drüben zur Butter gebe ich Tomatenmark.
Jetzt ein bisschen mit anbraten.
Nicht zu hoch stellen,
damit die Butter nicht verbrennt mit dem Tomatenmark.
Und da gibt es auch Unterschiede.
Da kann man jetzt entweder Tomatenmark nehmen
oder man nimmt einfach Paprikapulver.
Das mag ich auch sehr gerne,
aber mit Tomatenmark finde ich es auch lecker.
Also, wenn ich aber entscheiden müsste...
Ich will es heute so ein bisschen suppiger lassen.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt Tomatenmark genommen,
weil ich es gleich mit ein bisschen von dem Wasser serviere.
Aber ich mag es auch gern,
wenn man Paprikapulver nimmt und das da so darüberleert.
Vielleicht mache ich es noch dazu.
Und wenn die Mantı dann so weit sind
– also normalerweise kocht man ja eine große Portion.
Ich habe das jetzt hier
für uns zwei, Josh.
Und wenn man eine große Portion kocht,
kann man im Prinzip jetzt dieses,
diese Tomatenbutter hier mit reingeben.
Man kann es so ein bisschen suppig lassen, also mit Soße,
oder man schöpft es eben komplett ab.
Ich gebe es jetzt hier allerdings in den kleinen Topf.
Denn da habe ich jetzt noch den Vorteil,
dass die Mantı nicht abkühlen.
Die bleiben einfach schön warm.
Ich gebe aber noch ein bisschen Soße dazu.
Ich finde es voll hübsch, wenn man das dann so serviert.
Und sie sind einfach nicht so schnell kalt.
Weil, wenn man jetzt den kalten Joghurt dazu gibt,
dann, finde ich, ist es oft relativ schnell kalt,
auch zu kalt,
aber so
– mmh! –
schön warm.
Ich mache jetzt noch eine schöne Portion für dich, Josh,
damit du gleich probieren kannst.
Du kriegst auch gleich eine große Portion, okay?
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Der kleine Josh kriegt gleich eine große Portion.
Aber zuerst machen wir die Fotoportion
und danach kriegst du eine große Portion.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also hier wird jeder satt.
Er wird nicht verhungern.
Nicht, dass es gleich heißt, die Sally, die geizige,
gibt dem armen Josh nur das kleine Pfännchen.
Es sah nämlich jetzt schon so aus, gell?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen.
>> JOSH: Ach so, das Pfännchen!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Sonst sieht es so aus,
als würdest du nichts bekommen bei uns.
Aber du kriegst gleich. Versprochen!
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und wer will,
kann zum Beispiel noch Petersilie darübergeben.
Aber ich finde, so pur schmeckt es einfach am besten,
einfach nur mit Joghurt.
Zack!
Okay.
Komm, hau die Kamera auf das Stativ
und komm mal probieren.
Ich bin echt gespannt!
>> JOSH: So. Also...
>> SALLY: Ich bin so gespannt!
>> JOSH: Ich bin auch sehr, sehr gespannt.
>> SALLY: Also, was ich noch darübermache
– warte ich schöpfe die kurz noch raus, die letzten.
>> JOSH: Okay.
Ja, die handgemachten,
die müssen alle sorgsam behandelt werden.
>> SALLY: Die,
da hat jedes einzelne meinen Respekt, meine Würdigung,
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: meine Anerkennung verdient.
>> JOSH: Du hast auch meinen Respekt,
dir so einen Aufwand zu machen.
>> SALLY: Siehst du?
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: So.
>> JOSH: Also ich glaube, wenn, dann würde ich die
>> SALLY: Die Rollen?
>> JOSH: die schnellere Variante nachmachen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Vielleicht würde ich auch Maultaschen machen.
>> SALLY: So zwanzigmal so groß.
>> JOSH: Weil die sind zwanzigmal so groß.
Vielleicht.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde schon, die müssen schon so
>> JOSH: Aber es ist cool.
Nee, es ist ein saucooles Gericht.
>> SALLY: schon so klein sein.
>> JOSH: Also es sieht Hammer aus!
>> SALLY: Genau. Und jetzt noch eine Prise Chili.
>> JOSH: Ah, okay.
Oh ja, das passt gut.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt probier mal.
>> JOSH: So.
Jetzt so ein bisschen Joghurt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich probiere auch mal einen Löffel, um zu gucken,
>> JOSH: Ein bisschen Chili.
>> SALLY: ob es so schmeckt,
wie ich es mir gewünscht habe.
>> JOSH: Okay.
Mmh!
Zu wenig Salz?
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen.
>> JOSH: Aber richtig gut!
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> JOSH: Sehr, sehr, sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: Lohnt sich der Aufwand, oder?
>> JOSH: Auf jeden Fall!
Also die Kombination mit diesem Tomaten,
ein bisschen Chili, Joghurt,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: das habe ich eh voll kennengelernt,
wo ich mit dem Murat in der Türkei war.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Also hat mir immer echt gut gefallen
so mit viel Joghurt.
>> SALLY: Und ich bin schockiert,
dass du es noch nicht gegessen hast.
Denn ihr wart doch schon in Kayseri.
>> JOSH: Ja, stimmt!
>> SALLY: Da kommt das doch her.
>> JOSH: Da haben wir ja die Gusseisentöpfe
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: gedreht. Kann ich übrigens sehr empfehlen,
das Video, falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: die Herstellung von den Gusseisentöpfen.
>> SALLY: Komm, wir probieren noch die hier.
>> JOSH: Ach, stimmt.
Und das haben wir dort gar nicht gegessen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Deswegen. Ich bin voll schockiert.
Also würde ich nach Kayseri reisen
– ich selbst war noch nie dort.
>> JOSH: Ach Gott!
Hey Murat, warum haben das nicht gegessen dort?
>> MURAT: Wir haben das gegessen.
Du hast das vergessen, weil es so viel war.
>> JOSH: Ja, okay, das kann sein.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> JOSH: Vielleicht. Ja, vielleicht.
Wer weiß?
Das...
Wir haben echt viel gegessen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Jetzt probieren wir noch die anderen, die Rollen.
>> JOSH: Wo sind – ach so, das sind jetzt da die Röllchen.
>> SALLY: Hier die Ecke.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Schmecken auch wunderbar.
Ich finde, bei den anderen
hat man so verschiedene Konsistenzen,
weil Rand und Mitte.
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde die also...
>> JOSH: Also diese Taschen
haben schon was für sich.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Und bei den Rollen merkt man,
dass man immer so ein
– so ein rundes Ding.
Und diese geformten,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: die haben halt so eine
Haptik im Mund halt.
>> SALLY: Was ein Zufall!
>> JOSH: Das ist schon ausgefallen.
>> SALLY: Josh, was ein Zufall! Ich habe noch drei
– o mein Gott! Chili!
>> JOSH: Alles okay?
Okay?
>> SALLY: Mir ist es nicht zu scharf.
Mir ist es nur voll
>> JOSH: Ja, ja, wenn man es so einatmet und dann...
>> SALLY: in den Hals gerutscht.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte sagen: Was ein Zufall!
Ich habe noch vier Teigkugeln übrig.
Dann können wir zwei jetzt noch
die übrigen Mantı formen.
Und ihr könnt das Rezept gerne ausprobieren.
>> JOSH: Okay. Ich habe dann heute nichts mehr vor.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und falls ihr auch ein Mantı-Rezept habt
aus einem anderen Land, aus Russland,
aus Afghanistan,
aus egal woher,
dann schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare
und dann probieren wir gerne
auch noch Mantı-Spezialitäten
>> JOSH: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: von der ganzen Welt aus.
>> JOSH: Die gibt es doch bestimmt auch
mit anderen Füllungen, oder?
>> SALLY: Na klar!
Kartoffel.
>> JOSH: Oh, cool!
>> SALLY: Vegan kann man sie auch machen.
>> JOSH: Ja, stimmt. Weil die sind ja
nicht ganz vegan.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Fast.
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Wir machen jetzt Fotos und essen schnell.
Tschüss!
Afiyet olsun!
Sag mal du: "Afiyet olsun!"
>> JOSH: O Gott! Da blamiere ich mich nur.
>> SALLY: Komm, sag was Türkisches.
Afiyet olsun!
>> JOSH: Merhaba!
Tja,
mal schauen, ob ich satt werde.
>> SALLY: Ja. Hoşçakal!
>> JOSH: Hoşçakal!
Ja.
[Musik]